what the taliban are doing or not doing
is has nothing to do with us you know
you have to speak to taliban about what
they're doing we're not responsible
neither are we some spokespersons for
taliban the taliban has retaken
afghanistan president ashraf ghani has
fled the u.s has evacuated the embassy
in kabul every day afghans have no idea
what comes next with the taliban
effectively patrolling the streets
it begs the question does anyone have
any kind of leverage any political sway
over this group the prime minister of
pakistan insists his nation has nothing
to do with the taliban but it's hard not
to look at afghanistan's eastern
neighbor right now when the taliban
which calls itself the islamic emirate
of afghanistan took over that country in
1996 under the helm of mulla omar it was
well known they had been helped by
pakistan's intelligence services the isi
i spoke to a former head of the isi back
in 2015 on al jazeera english even after
the u.s led invasion he said because the
taliban had support in the country and
were fighting foreign intervention
pakistan was happy to help back them to
get the group to the negotiating table
he said
if a wreck tech malaysia
of 2025 000
insurgents
with the help of a state which is
considered to be either failing or
faltering or fumbling like pakistan
if they can achieve this particular
status
then the lease that i expect from an
audience like this
in a country where you know they talk
about the spirit of eden and hero
to give the taliban and their supporters
in pakistan a big applause
pakistan continues to play a role in
negotiations with the group
participating in the doha peace talks
between the taliban and the afghan
government alongside the u.s and china
whatever responsibility pakistan takes
with regard to the conflict across its
border the reality is the humanitarian
crisis is going to spill over more than
it already has
pakistan has hosted millions of afghan
refugees over the course of the us's
20-year war there and before that the
soviet occupation of afghanistan peaking
at three million registered refugees it
currently has nearly a million and a
half and countless unregistered afghan
refugees too pakistani officials now say
they can't accept any more
so
what kind of role should pakistan play
as the situation in afghanistan
continues to unfold earlier tonight i
spoke with the former foreign minister
of pakistan hina rabbanikar
thanks so much for joining me on the
show tonight pakistan as afghanistan's
neighbor to the east has historically
been the refuge for millions of
displaced afghans i believe it now has
almost 1.5 million registered refugees
earlier this month though the current
pakistani national security adviser
yusuf while in dc said pakistan can't
bear the burden of hosting more afghan
refugees the u.n says the current
situation in afghanistan could soon be a
humanitarian catastrophe is there
nothing more that pakistan can do to
help deal with that
um i think pakistan has a long history
of trying to do whatever it can to deal
with it and has also a long history of
taking all the flag for everything that
goes wrong in afghanistan
i think like any other state pakistan's
first responsibility is to protect its
own uh to be able to ensure that the
spillover from afghanistan does not
affect pakistan in the same way where it
bought a wave of terrorism as last time
and a wave of refugees and maybe i can
i'm sure you can appreciate that
pakistan is a country with scarce
resources we are currently in an imf
program for us to be able to bear or to
be expected to bear the burden of this
entire refugee influx and you quote the
number 1.5 million registered there are
many unregistered afghan refugees in
pakistan till today
so to expect pakistan to be able to bear
the burden of another few million i
think is
really my advice to our government is
that we need to really ensure that
pakistan is first able to concentrate on
its own internal problems and is able to
manage or ris
the spillover in the way where our
security our people our
territory our citizens are the first
that we protect you
you mentioned your advice to your
government pakistani prime minister the
current prime minister imran khan did an
interview with pbs newshour last month
and when asked about the us exit and the
taliban's growing resurgence at the time
this is what he said have a listen
here over the u.s for two decades in
afghanistan trying to force a military
solution the military solution failed
now what choices have we got the best
choice is that somehow
we have a political settlement of
afghanistan
where it is as i repeat an inclusive
government so taliban sit down with the
with with the other side and they form
an inclusive government
this is the best outcome
there is no other outcome
he's right that there is no military
solution but do you think pakistan is
going to be able to help broker the sort
of political outcome he talked about
because given your country's historic
role in aiding the afghan taliban
providing a safe haven for them on
pakistani soil even money and weapons
according to many isn't it incumbent
many would argue on pakistan to be
playing a leading role here in making
sure there is a peaceful political
solution in afghanistan that the taliban
are restrained
look i find it interesting that you use
these words to explain what happened in
pakistan and afghanistan because
providing safe havens is very different
than
not doing kinetic action against a group
which seek refuge like millions of other
afghans in pakistan's territory and for
a country or a state to choose to go
after those which were attacking our own
children and our own policemen and our
own soldiers which happened to be ttp
and many other extremist organizations
so please don't forget that pakistan has
had an influx of extremist organizations
at its own within its own territory that
pakistan has had to deal with so uh to
it for the world to expect that we would
leave all of that and concentrate and go
a full blast military action against
the avant taliban clearly did not happen
was not likely to happen
so as far as our responsibility is
concerned and our ability to engineer a
behavioral change in the taliban is
concerned i think that is an exaggerated
role and has been an exaggerated role
if not the last few decades at least for
the last few years i know as a matter of
fact and i think it is well documented
that the gtp the reca taliban pakistan
which has butchered our children
continues to have links with the tariq
alibaba
now if pakistan had the type of leverage
that the world expects of pakistan
wouldn't pakistan first ensure that the
tta and ttp were able to de-link and ttp
were to were to receive no support from
the tta now if pakistan is unable to
broker that for itself do you think
pakistan is able to broker the solution
when the u.s itself
and pakistan of course encouraged or
played whatever role it would but hold
on
hold on i take your point the pakistani
taliban have killed a lot of pakistani
civilians and the pakistani military has
fought with them that doesn't change the
fact and it is a fact that pakistan has
for strategic geopolitical reasons
supported the afghan taliban in
afghanistan you were foreign minister
from 2011 to 2013 are you telling me
that during that period when barack
obama was in office when there were
attempts to try and unwind the war then
are you telling me you had no knowledge
as foreign minister of anyone in your
defense establishment your isi
intelligence agency nobody had contacts
with the afghan taliban there were no
ties at the time because a lot of people
will find that hard to believe
look uh media i'm telling you that for
the 20 years that the united states of
america and nato partners were in
afghanistan i don't know a single year
where the cia did not have contact with
the apartheid
okay so this is what intelligence
agencies do they maintain those contacts
to have intelligence and to protect
their sovereign territorial boundaries
what i'm saying is that the leverage
that is expected of pakistan pakistan
perhaps never had and whatever leverage
pakistan had it used to bring them to
the table to the negotiating table and
then then it was for the americans and
the avant taliban to negotiate what was
supposed to be a peace negotiation which
turned out to be what we all know by now
a withdrawal negotiation and once you've
given them a date of exit what leverage
can anyone have what leverage can a
country like pakistan with 8 billion
dollars in defense spending as opposed
to the united states of america with 778
billion dollars of defense spending you
expect too much
i guess
i guess the question is not about
whether anyone's expecting pakistan to
fight the taliban so it's not really
about defense budgets it's about the
fact that for example in 1996 when the
taliban was taking over afghanistan
pakistan was one of only three
governments in the world that recognized
the taliban there are those
long-standing ties hussein haqqani who
i'm sure you know pakistan's former
ambassador to the united states he wrote
last month the pakistan support of
violent afghan groups like the taliban
quote will only embolden radicals at
home in pakistan and lead to more
attacks within the country he says quite
explicitly quote pakistan's generals see
the taliban as an important partner in
their competition with india he called
this taliban resurgence a pyrrhic
victory for pakistan
many would argue that in obsessing over
trying to defeat india afghanistan
became i don't know some form of
strategic depth and that's led to this
chaos today no one's excusing the u.s
role of course and we've discussed that
endlessly on this show the role of the
cia the role of american presidents both
republican and democrat
but surely it's time for pakistan to
take some responsibility for the
situation in afghanistan as well
look i think pakistan has taken more
than its share of the responsibility in
the last many many years and i think if
mr hussain
was not sitting in washington dc and was
sitting in pakistan he would understand
and know that 1996 and 2021
are very different i am proud to say
pakistan has made many mistakes but i'm
proud to say that pakistan
is perhaps one of the few countries left
which has learned the right lessons of
history and i feel where pakistan is
getting out of the black and going into
the sort of white or grey area
many countries are actually receding
right now okay so we are
very willing to accept the mistakes we
made in the past but what we're saying
is please do not judge pakistan of 2021
by the role that pakistan played in 1996
and not
united states created the mujahideen yes
we were left to deal with them but we
all played our role in creating these
monsters which are and i do agree with
the second half of what mr haqqani is
saying and this is what the pakistani
establishment and many political parties
in pakistan also believe that the tta or
any extremist organization taking
government through military strength and
i do not believe it was their military
strength or the lack they wrote or the
bad doll which made them do what they
did
really
uh encourages
powers i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in i'm
gonna jump in because we're out of time
but i do want
20 seconds 20 seconds left you used to
be very close to hillary clinton when
you were foreign minister america is an
ally of pakistan what is your message to
the biden administration tonight 20
seconds
i think my message to the biden
administration is that
the way we do not question their
decision to withdraw uh sooner or later
that had to be done but i think uh it is
true that the way the withdrawal was
conducted from the negotiations to it
became a complete withdrawal negotiation
and i think today many in the region
feel especially the afghan women and
afghan men and of one children
feel that they were left behind to deal
with a crisis which was not of their own
making we all had a role to play in
creating this crisis but they and after
that pakistan is the one who will have
to deal with whatever are the
repercussions the intended and the
unintended consequences of this rushed
withdrawal
hinarabanika we'll have to leave it
there thank you so much for coming on
the show tonight
hi i'm mehdi hassan thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show by
clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories thank you for watching